اذا في ما سميت بمصافحه المونديال لعلق
الرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان على مصفحه
رئيس المصريه عبد الفتاح السيسي في قطر
مؤكدا انها كانت الخطوه الاولى نحو
التطبيع وتاسيس السلام مع مصر وبحسب وسائل
اعلام تركيا على اردوغان انه يريد ان تكون
الاجتماعات مع مصر على مستوى اعلى
واستئناف محادثات التطبيعه واضاف اردوغان
ان الطلبه الوحيده لتركيا من مصر هو تغيير
في الموقف بشان الثروات في شرق البحر
المتوسط
واكد مسؤول في رئاسه التركييه ان هذا هو
التواصل الثنائي الاول بين الرئيسين وذكرت
وكاله الاناضول انا اردوغان صفح الرئيس
السيسي واجرالي فتره وجيزه محادثات معه
ومع قاده اخرين بينهم رئيسه الفلسطيني
محمود عباس وملك الاردن عبد الله الثاني
[موسيقى]
هناقش هذا الموضوع مع ضيوفينا من اسطنبول
دكتور سمير صالحه للاستاذه في العلاقه
الدوليه اهلا بك ومن القاهره الدكتور سمير
غطاس رئيس منتدى الشرق الاوسط للدراسات
الاستراتيجيه اهلا بكم يا اهل الكريمين
واسمحالي ان ابدا من اسطنبول معك دكتور
صالحه دكتور صالحه في الواقع اذا عدنا
للتصريحات همم السابقه كان هناك تصريح في
سنه 2013 للرئيس اردوغان قال فيه لن اصافح
انقلابيين ولن التقي بتاتا مع الرئيس
المصري عبد الفتاح السيسي همم ما الذي
تغير منذ 2013 الى اليوم
صحيح مساء الخير للجميع اولا طبعا يعني
اتفق معاكي اذا ما عدنا الى الارشيف
نستطيع ان نجد فيه الكثير من المواقف
التصريحات
الحاده
لكن يبدو انه تركيا على ضوء المتغيرات في
سياساتها
هذه المصالحه التركيه مع العديد من
العواصم في المنطقه هذا التحول وما
سميناها دائما اعاده التموضع في العديد
دكتور صالح حتى ندخل في جوهر الموضوع ما
ابرز هذه المتغيرات يعني حظرتك هل تضع مصر
من ضمن مجموعه دول التوتر التصالح معها او
تمثيل العلاقات اكثر معها ام ان لمصر
خصوصيه في هذه الثنائيه من العلاقات
لا طبعا التحول في الموقف التركي الرسمي
حيان مصر قديم بدا اكثر من عامين
ولكن لم نصل الى نتيجه يعني الحوار
الاستكشافي الذي تم لم يؤدي الى نتائج بعد
الحوار الاستكشافي قبل ايامنا انا وانت
تصريحات وزير الخارجيه المصري سبع شكري
انه لا يوجد اي اختراق حقيقي في تعامل مع
ملف العلاقات بعد ذلك ايضا جاء تصريح
مولود شوش قولوا ليؤكد عدم حدوث تقدم ايضا
لذلك هذه المصافحه برايه اختراق حقيقي ليه
مرحله جديده في العلاقات انا وانت لا نعرف
تماما ما الذي دار بين الرئيسين في
حوارهما همم
القصير لا نعرف هل بعد هذه المصافحه كان
في لقاء جانبي مثلا طبعا لا نملك اي
معلومه او اي ما يوثق هذا الطريقه لماذا
انا دخل ايوه ولكن اعتبرتها على الاقل ان
اعتبرتها اختراق حقيقي خليني او اسمح لي
ان التقط منك هذه العباره وانقلها للدكتور
غطاس دكتور غطاس هل تعتبر بان هذه
المصافحه التي همم في الواقع همم انتبه
لها كثيرون وشده انتباها كثيرين هل
تعتبرها همم اختراقا حقيقيا وهل يمكن
البناء عليها كما يقول الرئيس اردوغان هي
خطوته الاولى لبنى مصاري امتن مع مصر
انا اعتقد انه توصيف ما حدث في الدوحه هو
انها اكبر واكثر من مصافحه دبلوماسيه
لكنها اقل ربما بكثير من حدوث اختراق او
التحرك نحو تطبيق لانه ما تزال هناك على
الاقل ثلاث قضايا اساسيه عالقه بين
الطرفين مصر يجب ان اثبت اولا ان مصر
رسميا لم تقم باي سلوك ادائي اتجاه تركيا
العكس هو تماما الصحيح وبالتالي فان
المسؤوليه تقع
سياسيا على الجانب التركي ان يصلح ما
افسده وهو منذ 2013 حتى الان اذا سالتيني
عن الاسباب في تغير موقف تركي حتى الان
استطيع ان نلخصها في نقاط عديده نمره واحد
انه ما يسمى به مشروع العثمانيه الجديده
وصل الى منتهاها وافلس تماما وبالتالي فان
اردوغان مضطر لان يعود مره اخرى الى سياسه
وزير خارجيه السابق اوغلو الذي دعا الى
تصفير المشاكل مع كل الدول وخاصه الدول
العربيه اثنين ان اردوغان مقدم على
انتخابات وهو يريد ان يدخل هذه الانتخابات
باوراق قويه تلاته ان اردوغان يقيم علاقات
حاره الان او دافئه على الاقل مع الجانب
الاسرائيلي ويريد ان يوازن ما بين علاقته
مع الجانب الاسرائيلي حيث استقبل الرئيس
الاسرائيلي في انقره وهلنا نتنياهو اخيرا
على فوزه بالانتخابات وايضا ارسل تعازيه
على مقتل ثلاثه من المستوطنين
الاسرائيليين في عمليه فدائيه في
فلسطينيين وبالتالي هو يريد ان يوازن ما
بين هذه ما بين هذه العلاقات الدافئه مع
الجانب الاسرائيلي بعلاقات مع مصر ثلاثه
او اربعه انه يعرف انه بدون العلاقه مع
مصر لا يمكن ان يؤدي الى تطبيع في الشرق
الاوسط هو يدرك قيمه مصر الحقيقيه
وبالتالي هو سعى ويم ان تكون مصر مرحبه
بهذا السعي لكن اؤكد مره اخرى ان هناك على
الاقل ثلاث قضايا عالقه ما تزال بحاجه الى
جهد كبير حتى نسمي ما حصل انه اختراق طيب
ساعود لك فيما يخص كذلك الجنابه المصري
الجانب المصري الاكيد بانه لديه نقاط
ولديه هو كذلك همم تغيرات عاشها طيله هذه
السنوات ولكن همم هذه المتغيرات التي
تحدثت عنها دكتور غطاس دكتور همم صالحه
الى اي مدى تتفق مع ضيفي في انه اولا هو
لا يعتبره اختراقا حقيقيا يقول بان
الملفات الشائكه تبدو اعمق واثقل والمطالب
المصريه من تركيا همم لا تزال همم
لم تحقق فيها شيء ثابت شيء فعلا
يعني انا اظن جانب المصري ايضا
جاهز لي مراجعه سياسته في التعامل مع
العديد من الملفات التي تعني انقره بشكل
او باخر وصول منتدى الطاقه الذي تم
التاسيس له في القاهره وصل الى طريق مسدود
لماذا العديد من الاطراف التي كانت شريكه
في هذا المنتدى الانثق معها تركيا بشكل
مباشر عفوا مصالحات بين تركيا واسرائيل
تقارب واضح بين تركيا والامارات
وخسارها العديد من الدول للرهان على الورق
اليونانيه الان التي باتت معزوله اكثر
فاكثر بسبب مواقفها
وسياساتها في اكثر من دافئه برايي بينه
ايضا وصول القياده المصريه الى قناعه انه
التقارب التركي على المصري ب- ب- بيطبع
اقليمي قادر على صناعه الكثير من
الانجازات التي تخدم
صالح الطرفين لذلك القياده المصريه ايضا
جاهزه برايي نعم لفتح هذه الصفحه الجديده
باختصار الرئيس اردوغان في طريق العوده من
الدوحه تحدث عند الاعلام وانا رايي انه
طرح خريطه طريق في ربما حسب تصوريه هو في
شكل المرحله المقبله من العلاقات التركيه
المصريه عندما قال انه سيكون نقترح يعني
او الهدف هو لقاءات وزاريه وبعد ذلك لقاء
همم
نعم مثل هذه المسائل تم طرحها ونقشات
ويبدو انه في تفهمات ربما حولها حتى اتفق
دكتور
لا لا صحيح هناك ثلاثه قضايا متى زال
عالقه حتى الان القضيه الاولى هي ملف
الاخوان المسلمين وحتى الان كل ما وعدت به
تركيا عادت عنه وتنكرت له مؤخرا تم عقد
مؤتمر في
تركيا لما يسمى بالتيار الثالث وهو الطيار
الذي يعلن تمسكه بمساله الكفاح المسلح او
ما يسمى بالارهاب في داخل مصر وهذا يعني
يجب ان يتوقف تماما مصر طالبت بتسليم عدد
من قيادات صادره بحقها احكام ولا يقول
لاحد ان تركيا ترفض التسليم سابقا في خمسه
فبراير 2019
سلمت تركيا محمد عبد الحفيظ حسين وهو متهم
في قضيه اغتيال النائب العام
وسلمت ايضا تركيا القصه الامريكي عندما
طلبت به الولايات المتحده الامريكيه سلمته
وبالتالي ما يزال ملف الاخوان المسلمين
رغم بعد الاجراءات التي رحبت بها حول
تقنين وجود دكتور دكتور
ولكن صحيح ولكن حضرتك ما الذي تقصده
بالقول بان تركيا سلمت في مقابل فلا
تقولوا لي بان تركيا لا تسلم وكانك تشير
الى ان تركيا تستخدم ملف الاخوان وتسليم
من هم همم او من صدر في حقهم حكم في داخل
المصري تستعمل هذا الملف للضغط او لتسيير
بعض الملفات الاخرى
عندما نتحدث عن ضروره تسليم ارهابيين
ودانيين في مصر وتجري محاكماتهم في مصر
وجلت محاكماتهم في مصر وتطلب مصر تسليم
وهم وفقا للقواعد الدوليه يقولون لنا في
تركيا ان من حيث المبدا تركيا ترفض تسليم
همم يعني همم اشخاص موجودين على اراضيهم
ذكرت ان محمد حسين محمد عبد الحفيظ حسين
وذكرت قصه الاميريكي وهي تدل على انه لا
يوجد ما يسمى بمبدا عدم التسليم ومصر ويجب
ان تقبل
همم تركيا تسليم مدانين في قضايا ارهاب في
مصر هؤلاء تجري محاكماتهم مره اخرى عند
تسليمهم كما حصل مع عديد من الذين اعيدوا
الى مصر مره اخرى هذا ملف الاخوان وملف
الاخوان ما يزال عالقا ولم تقدم تركيا الا
القليل في هذا الملف الملف الثاني هو
ترسيم الحدود البحريه وهذا ملف الاهم
وذكره الرئيس التركي هنا يجب ان نسكن ان
تركيا هي البلد الوحيد في منطقه الشرق
الاوسط التي لم تعلم قبولها بقرار الامم
المتحده حول قانون المياه 1982 الذي يحدد
عمق المياه الاقليميه الاقتصاديه تركيا لا
تقبل ورفضت تماما قبوله هذا القرار
وبالتالي لا يمكن اعاده ترسيم الحدود الا
بعد ان تعلن اولا تركيا وافقتها على قرار
الامم المتحده الخاص بقانون البحار وتقبل
القرار هذا القرار الذي صدر 28 1982
قبل قبل الذهاب الى نقطه الملف الليبي
سابقى معك بخط- بخصوص ترسيم الحدود
البحريه وما تحدث عنه الرئيس اردوغان هو
تقدم بمطلب قال بانه هذه النقاشات او هذا
المسار التفاوضى مع مصر همم
يمثل اذا ما غيرت مصر موقفها في ما يخص
اثر واحد في شرح في شرق البحر المتوسط هل
تعتقد دكتور صالح بانه هذا قادر ان يقبل
من الجهه المصريه لان ضيف يقول لك بانه
على تركيا ان تحدد كذلك مواقفها بل اكثر
من ذلك ان همم
همم يعني تنفذ ما جاء من اتفاقات بالظبط
من اتفاقات الدوليه سابقه
يعني موضوع الطاقه في شرق المتوسط الجزئيه
في النقاش التركي المصري صحيح الرئيس
اردوغان اشار اليه لكنه رئيس اردوغان اشار
الى اكثر من ماده ايضا في موضوع العلاقات
التركيه المصريه يعني ركز على اهميه عوده
هذه العلاقات كما صالح تخدم البلدين هذه
النقطه برايه كما قلت لك اجانب المصري
الان يعرفها تماما المساله ليست مرتبطه
بموضوع الاخوان براي انا انه هذا الملف
همم انتهى تقريبا لم يعد فيه نقاشات همم
بذات قيمه في هذا المدلول والدليل انه
انقر الان تناقش مع القاهره ملفات بطابعه
اقليمي استراتيجي اكثر من الموضوع
على الموضوع شائك ولم ينتهي هذا ما همم
دكتور غطاس عليه
هذا ما كنت هذا ما كنت ساقوله لك باختصار
طبعا لا تعطيني بعض الوقت ايضا ثم اعطيتي
الكريم
في مشكله اساسيه هنا في التحليل وقراءه
الاخوه في مصر لمسالتين موضوع اتفاقيه
قانون البحار 82 التي لم توقعتها تركيا
تحفظت عليها هذا مرتبط بسياسه تركيا
المائيه مع اليونان في ايجا في شرق
المتوسط توتر في ملفات متداخله مائيه يرفض
الجانب اليوناني الجلوس ومناقشتها اليونان
تستقوي بالاتفاقيات ال- اتفاقيه القانون
البحار لانها وقعتك جزء ايضا من المجموعه
الاوروبيه لا احد بمقدودها ان يلزم تركيا
بتوقيع اتفاقيه من هذا النوع اذا ذهبنا
الى طائره حوار واتمنى جزئيات من هذه
الاتفاقيه نعم هذا ممكن بالنسبه لي انقره
لكن الحديث انه انقر لم توقع وكانه تركيا
يعني تتهرب او انما هذه المساله لا تعني
مصر لا من قريب ولا من بعيد الان في نقطه
اهم ايضا انه هذا النقاش الذي نتحدث عنه
في موضوع الاخوان تسنيم مطلوبين لمصر نعم
تسليم مطلوبين مساله موجوده في الاتفاقيات
بين الدول تسليم مطلوبين هذه مره اقولها
بشكل واضح لضيفك يعرف ان المساله افضل مني
تسليم مطلوبين او بمحاكمه الاعدام هذه
مساله مستحيله بين المستحيلات بالنسبه
للتركيا حدث حدث همم مساله فرديه واشعلت
الداخل التركي مطولا كيف تمت عمليه
التسليم ولماذا انا اعود الى نقطه
الاساسيه انه تركيا جزء من اتفاقيه المجلس
الاوروبي معاهدات واتفاقيات مع المجموعه
الاوروبيه بعدم تسليم منهم مطلوبين بحكم
الاعدام اظن جانب المصري يعرف ذلك افضل
مني لذلك الاصرار على تسليم اشخاص مطلوبين
بهذا هذه تهنئه بهذا الحكم هذه بين
المستحيلات بالنسبه لانقرك وهي في كل
الحالات مجموعه من النقاط ومن الملفات
بالغه الاهميه وملفات شائكه ستكون على
طويله القاده اذا ما كان هناك حياه لما
بعد هذه المصافحه ولكن اختم معكما بسؤال
لكما وسابدا معك دكتور غطاس نتحدث عن
منسوب الثقه والثقه شيء مهم جدا بين
الاطراف في مثل هكذا مراحل هل تعتقد بان
هناك نسبه ثقه همم او احد ادنى من الثقه
كافن للبناء على ما بعد هذه المصافحه
يعني ما يسمى بالعلاقات التركيه المصريه
لم تبدا بالمصافحه هي وصلت الى حد
المصافحه لكن بدات بمقابلات مع اجهزه
المخابرات في كل من البلدين ثم اللقاءات
على مستوى الوزراء ثم وصلت الان للاسباب
التي اشارتي اليها لجانب الوساطه النشطه
من قطر التي هي الوسيط المعتمد من قبل
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه والتي لها
علاقه ثنائيه بكلا الطرفين وبالتالي كانت
هذه فرصه لعقد هذه المصافحه قلت ان
المصافحه هي اكبر من مصافحه دبلوماسيه
لكنها اقل بكثير من التحدث عن اختراق
حقيقي بدون تسويه الملفات التي اشرت اليها
اسهلها الاخوان المسلمين بالتاكيد لكن لا
يمكن الحديث عن مصالحه في ظل تماسك عدم
توقيع تركيا على اتفاقات القناه وهي تريد
اصلا المشكله الاساسيه هي تريد ترسيم
الحدود البحريه مع مصر على حساب او مدينه
في ترسيم الحدود مع اليونان وهذا امر لا
يمكن ان يحدث في بالنسبه للجانب المصري
الى جانب القضيه التي يعني يجب ان يكون
هناك يعني وقت المتسع للحديث عنها
ولكن الدكتور صالح هل هناك احد ادنى من
الثقه لدى القاده للبناء على هذه المصافحه
تعتقد
ما سمعته انا تصريحات مواقف الرئيس التركي
في تاريخ العوده من الدوحه اظن انه انقر
الان تقدم اكثر من ورقه بشكل مكشوف باتجاه
الجانب المصري وضع شروط مسبقه قبل الذهاب
مجددا الى الحوار سواء كان على مستوى همم
الوزراء او غير ذلك اظن انه هذا سيعقد
المال الامر اكثر فاكثر انا اظن القيادات
المصريه الان هي يعني عندها الكره في
ملعبها لتتعامل مع تصريحات الرئيس التركي
رجب طيب اردوغان في اطار اي اتجاه ستقر
وتحسن مواقفه
من اسطنبول الدكتور سمير صالح في العلاقه
الدوليه شكرا لك همم من القاهره دكتور
سمير غطاس رئيس منتدى الشرق الاوسط
الدراسات الاجتماعيه شكرا لكم